si quieren tener civismo nuevamente
esto es hacer campaña en era de pandemia
respetando las reglas de distanciamiento
social desde iowa minnesota y hasta
wisconsin yo bailé incluso tres estados
en un día en una región de eeuu que
podría ser clave en las elecciones esta
zona industrial y rural también ha visto
un aumento dramático en los casos de
coronavirus baiden se apresuró a
recordarle a la gente quien cree que es
el culpable
[Música]
ese es el mismo hombre que hace semanas
cuando le dijeron que estábamos
perdiendo mil vidas al día recuerdas lo
que dijo dijo es lo que es
trump ha ondeado la bandera blanca y se
ha rendido a este virus
para no quedarse atrás donald trump
llegó a minnesota wisconsin y michigan
en el mismo día con la promesa de
restaurar la vida normal incluso cuando
los hospitales locales alcanzan su
capacidad máxima
el presidente también se apresuró a
culpar a su oponente por el verano de
violencia wisconsin entre activistas
anti racistas y milicias de extrema
derecha
by denny la extrema izquierda incitan a
la violencia con su vil retórica anti
policial y el hecho de que son gente
débil gente muy muy débil permite que
los alborotadores arrasan con las calles
públicas que fueron financiadas por
ustedes a pablo x prize
va a estar decidido a no cometer el
mismo error que hillary clinton en 2016
quien se olvidó de hacer campaña en los
llamados estados del muro azul como
wisconsin lo que permitió a tron
ganarlos por un muy estrecho margen